My name is Eric Bersin,
and I am a graduate student
in the quantum
photonics group at MIT.
And my research in particular
deals with quantum computing.
So quantum computing is
a new type of computing
that harnesses the principles
of quantum mechanics
to do computations in a
fundamentally different way.
And in particular, this allows
for more powerful calculations
of certain types of
problems, ranging from things
like factoring large prime
numbers to calculating
interactions for biochemistry.
And so quantum
computing has been
around for some
number of years now.
And we're starting
to get to the point
where we actually have systems
of multiple quantum bits
or qubits.
And we're starting
to try to put them
into large numbers of systems
on chip in particular.
And quantum
computing is actually
experiencing a lot
of the same problems
that classical
computing experienced,
namely that when you have lots
of systems all in one chip,
very close together, you start
to have problems with crosstalk
and problems and trying to
address individual qubits
at the same time.
And so my work in
particular is trying
to look at how we can develop
new techniques for individually
addressing systems of qubits.
And particularly the
system that we look at
is a nitrogen vacancy
center in diamond.
So essentially this is a
defect, a single atom defect
inside of a crystal lattice.
And so that helps
us get pretty far.
So we have single
atom qubits, which
is pretty small
and pretty compact.
But it turns out that
actually to talk these qubits,
you need to use lasers
and optical addressing.
And for those who are
familiar with optics,
you may know that
there's something called
the diffraction
limit, which means
that the smallest you
can make a laser spot
is roughly half the wavelength.
And so that sort of places
a fundamental limit,
you would think, on how narrowly
you can address these qubits,
and how tightly
you can pack them.
So what we were able
to help actually
through part of my master's
work was the technique
for using small differences
between these qubits
and slight differences in
their transition frequencies
as a result of their environment
to individually address
qubits with very, very high
precision and high fidelity.
And so we showed
that we could have
an ensemble of multiple
different qubits,
these little atom like
defects in diamond
and address a
single one at a time
without perturbing the
state of the other.
So we think this is really a
path forward towards having
really scalable systems with
very densely packed information
on a single chip for
quantum computing.